every thought you have is a magical
lie how do we live a life with
zero physical or mental weakness it's
loneliness comes from the fear
of the ego itself only do the things
that you love
ladies and gentlemen we have a living
legend in the house without today
mr deepak chopra how you doing man
excellent how are you
i'm great there's so many things to talk
about
in a limited amount of time we've got
your fitbit partnership you've got your
91st book total meditation your chopra
meditation app
some of the i see it there on on your on
your desk i guess here the total
meditation
amazing where i want to actually lead
off is and for anybody who wants
your projects we're going to link it up
in the description below so guys go
check that out
i was speaking to somebody my community
yesterday named patricia
who's a huge fan of yours she listens to
you every morning
she has your meditation on in her ears
she loves your calm
soothing voice and she starts her day
every day with a deepak chopra
meditation
and i asked her hey i'm talking to him
tomorrow if you have
one question for deepak chopra what
would it be
and her question was what brings you
to your place of strength and peace at
the same time
what brings me to a place of strength
and
peace is i don't believe
the lies of the mind
every every thought you have is a
magical
lie it's an
of interpretation perceptual experience
which is
radically untrue so for example
my perception tells me the earth is flat
nobody believes that anymore
my perception tells me that the ground
i'm sitting on is stationary and i know
it's spinning at dizzying speeds
and hurtling through space at thousands
of miles an hour
my perception tells me that i'm looking
at your body
but actually i'm not it's a perceptual
activity in myself
so a while ago i decided not to believe
my mind and what i do is step back
from the mind and watch it
and i noticed that there's me
watching it and what is me watching it
it's watching the
party it's watching my thoughts it's
watching you
it's watching everything else so stand
in front of a mirror and the mirror
reflects everything not just you but
everything else
is happening and if you understand that
the
entire world is a mirror of you
filtered through the crazy mind then you
don't depend on the mind
you depend on the awareness of the mind
so when i see a situation whatever it is
good bad
word whatever i ask myself who's
watching
and then i pay attention to the watcher
and i stay there and it's profoundly
peaceful and joyful at all times
how do we make that an intentional
practice
so that we don't have our instant
reaction to freak out or stress out or
um how do we go from making it that
instant reaction to an intentional
practice well a lot of people
say you know i want to quieten my mind
and then they struggled
in meditation but trying to quieten the
mind is a thought so it's also the mind
so you can't use the mind to quiet
the mind right all you have to do is ask
yourself
what am i aware of right now and then
favor
the awareness instead of the experience
because the experience
is a projection of the mind
awareness is independent awareness is
infinite possibilities
it's limitless it's beyond imagination
it's
infinite it's the real you that recycles
as body mind
people talk about reincarnation but
reincarnation is happening
every second every thought that you have
is reincarnated thought
every perception that you have is
actually a recycled perception
we just get bamboozled as soon as we're
given a name so you know i was given the
name deepak
chopra now that is a symbol
of who i am it's not who i am but
you know if you repeat somebody's name
enough your david your david you're
david
then the poor kid is screwed because he
thinks he's david
when in fact he's the infinite being
with a name called david
so you know you're not your name your
name is a symbol of who you are
if i'm looking at a menu in a book
and all these beautiful dishes are there
i can't
eat the menu okay so we use
words as symbols and of course you know
spiritual literature says
first there was the word and the word
was with god and god
you know became the word or whatever
there's some truth in that
as soon as you use words
you create form so if i ask you what is
this
it's a book but actually it's a color
it's a shape it's a form
if a baby was looking at this book it
would be squiggles
shapes forms and colors no idea that
this is a book and the baby is called
david
no idea it's a joyful experience because
the baby would see
this and everything else as itself and
would fall
in fact is in love with existence all
you have to look
at is a baby the only time it says
is when it's hungry or it's wet
otherwise
it's in bliss and why is it in bliss
because it hasn't been bamboozled
by constructs and is that ultimately
your mission is to guide people towards
bliss
yes if people could understand the
magnificence of who they are
that the fundamental state is bliss and
joy
and awareness and existence which is
timeless
see the body is in time the mind is in
time every thought is in time every
perception is in time
every image you have in your mind is in
time
except you the one that's awareness so
once you get to that this is what is
called the spiritual experience it's
also
actually the original religious
experience whether it's jesus or
muhammad the buddha doesn't matter
the religious experience is just three
things first you know
yourself beyond body and mind
second you have the emergence of
platonic truth
which is goodness harmony peace
empathy compassion love kindness joy
and the third religious experience not
religion i'm not talking about religious
dogma
religious experience loss of the fear of
death
if you have those three things you know
your true self
you have the emergence of what we call
platonic values truth goodness beauty
harmony love compassion joy equanimity
and you lose the fear of death what left
you're free
so along those lines i was watching a
video of yours recently called total
happiness now
and you had this line that i had to
pause on and you said
almost everybody gets some infirmity i'm
planning not to
and i didn't know what infirmity meant
so i had to pause the video and go look
it up and it said
at least the dictionary was physical or
mental weakness
how do we live a life with zero
physical or mental weakness
you see it's almost like the world
is so fooled
by insanity
it's not a measure of sanity
to adjust to or become used to insanity
right now when i look at the world i see
insanity
climate change mass migrations with
epidemics
racism bigotry hatred prejudice power
mongering
influence peddling extinction of species
nuclear weapons other ways of mechanized
death
poison and the food chain i think that's
insanity if you don't think it's
insanity
then you're declaring your own insanity
so
i it's okay to be
sane even if you're the only one in the
world
okay it's okay to be seen so
right now everybody says you know as you
grow old you get infirm
you get decrepitude you might get
alzheimer's you might lose mental
capacity you probably get diabetes
cancer heart disease why do we
say that because it seems everybody does
okay so we say that's the norm
but everybody accepts climate change
right now almost
everybody accepts war everybody accepts
terrorism everybody accepts is fine to
use mechanized death to kill people and
other species
is that true is that how it
should be so i come from a tradition by
the way
wisdom traditions where there's a thing
called maha samadhi
maha means big samadhi means the big
meditation
when you choose you say okay
been there done that i had a great life
my father
did that by the way my father was a
cardiologist
and trained in england so at the end of
his life he said i had a great innings
and you know he used to play cricket so
i had a great innings it's over
so i'm going to say goodbye and then he
closed his eyes
and you know he actually went to the
room where my mother was sleeping
said goodbye to her went back to his
room sat in bed closed his eyes and he
was gone
now yeah he probably had a cardiac
arrhythmia or something there has to be
something that causes the final
exit right but as far as i'm concerned
he died in peace
and in contentment and
without fear that is called mahasamadhi
it's a tradition
amongst my gurus going back thousands of
years
and so of course they don't talk about
it they
they're you know they don't they don't
care what the world thinks of them
they're not on twitter or instagram
or doing youtube videos they're happy
and you know i get that i get
that i'm 74 right now
my blood pressure is 110 over 70 my
cholesterol is younger than
better than anybody who's 40 years of
age my heart rate variability says i
have no stress
i enjoy every day a joyful energetic
body
love and compassion in my heart clear
mind
and lightness of being if you have those
four things
there's nothing else you want everything
else is like crumbs you know like
what do you call it dessert a little bit
cherry on the
on the top of the cake the reality
is joy at all times
how do you know when you're ready for
that final meditation i mean i look at
you
someone who's happy and content and
joined and
in health and yet also still very much
mission driven and so many exciting
projects and 91 books and all these
things you're still working on
how do you know when you're ready for
that final meditation everything i do by
the way
like books and everything talking to you
is is to
help people understand that they have
this
magnificence and bliss within them
so i'm not mission driven i i just shoot
the breeze you know
and people seem to enjoy it so i shoot
some more it looks like somebody's
singing in the bathroom
people are liking the song so if you say
oh somebody is liking the song you sing
more that's it i'm not bishop driven i
think hard work
exacting plans driving ambition
and you know focusing on
goals all the time is the refuge of the
failure
i think if you have joy everything
spontaneously helps you and actually if
you're not thinking of yourself you're
thinking about others
everybody helps you too so you know they
come along and they say hi
how can i help you i love it it's a it's
a big
mind twist at least for a typical kind
of north american
perspective audience and so um you know
thank you for sharing that here
on my channel uh let's let's
move that towards the fitbit partnership
because i think it all ties nicely
together so
i love fitbit i'm i've been a customer
for years
i was wearing one i just took a shower
so i took it off but
yes this is just a step tracker where i
try to get 20 to 40 000 steps a day i've
been using this for years and i was so
excited to see
deepak chopra is partnering with fitbit
this is crazy and so at least to my
understanding of it they've got the
watch that then can track
all sorts of vitals but including your
stress levels and so then what happens
if my watch says
hey evan you're stressed out right now i
get an
alert that then says do a deepak chopra
breathing routine or
say this mantra or like how does that
how do we go from stressed out
on my watch to you entering the picture
so i would rather that you not get an
alert
because that means i'm interfering with
uh you know your lifestyle of whatever
if you want to make a change then you
decide to make the change
now what can what the fitbit does is it
gives you your heart rate variability
gives you oxygen saturation
electrodermal activity
breathing rate core body temperature
in other words in real time you have
biometrics
right there on your wrist then you have
33
mindfulness interventions or breathing
interventions or
other insights from me deepak
on me the guy called deepak and
then you can use those to actually in
real time
change your metrics now that's called
bioregulation
okay biofeedback has been there for a
long time you know people do biofeedback
through electroencephalograms
through cardiac variability etc but
bioregulation means not only are getting
feedback but you can regulate
your mind and your body and that the
same thing by the way body and mind is
one unit like
mass and uh and energy like wave and
particle
like uh actuality and potentiality like
space and time
it's one entity whatever happens in the
mind happens in the brain
body whatever happens the brain reflects
back to the mind
they're a correlated activity for the
first time now
with fitbit by the way there's no other
place where we can do this right now
it's the first you get to
bio regulate your own biology
it's crazy so nine minutes before
starting this with you i went
to post a story to my instagram saying
i'm nervous i'm freaking out my heart's
beating fast you know i hope this
interview goes well
i'm sure my fitbit would be freaking out
to say heart rate off the chains
what what exercise would you
give somebody like me you know 15
minutes ago
uh to do before having to go do that
thing that they're nervous about
so even if you sat down quietly close
your eyes
observed your breath and took an
inhalation to the count of
four pause to the count of
two exhale to the count of six
your breathing rate will come down from
14 to about eight
if you do that for a minute just one
minute
if you go a little bit beyond that once
you get comfortable with that
you increase it so breathe in to six
positive breathe out six your brain
waves will go from
beta to alpha alpha is a meditative
state
but if you actually become good at this
i can take my brain waves down to
theta which is the dream state and then
if i want i can actually take it down
to four the breathing rate with practice
slowly but comfortably that
takes you to delta which is depressed
the equivalent
of deep sleep okay and you're still
awake of course but you're rested
the equivalent of deep sleep for that
one minute so i would say take a
breathing break
or just ask yourself am i aware and then
shift from the
thought to the awareness in which that
thought is
happening and notice that awareness
and hang in there and you'll be fine
immediately i love it here's another
thing yeah i call it the stop formula
s-t-o-p
s stands for stop t take three deep
breaths and smile from your head to your
toe
everywhere your fingernails your eyes
your nose your
mouth your heart even your genitalia are
smiling
and then um observe
your body feel it and then choose
the response you want at that moment
on or you can even make it simpler press
the pause button
pause breathe and choose
in looking at your work over the past
number of decades you've really
been at the front of helping make
meditation
an everyday thing i mean in the 80s
nobody knew about meditation and now
everybody knows what meditation is me
personally i think
meditation has helped a lot with just
mindfulness and presence where i
struggle with it and maybe you've got
some insider guidance on this is
get into an altered state where it feels
like
hey i've been doing meditation for two
hours but it only feels like five
minutes
if i sit down for an hour i'm present
i'm mindful i'm focused but it still
feels like an hour
where am i on the meditation journey
that i need to like make the next
breakthrough
even if it feels like an hour if there
are
moments when you lose track of time you
say oh
where was i you were
infinite at that moment so don't
try and count the time
that you left the arena
or the theater of space time and
causality
the easier you are the more spontaneous
it will be
not in meditation you know when somebody
is having a good time what did they say
i lost track of time when somebody falls
in love
there's no time right you when you fall
in love with anything even an idea
time goes you fall in love with the
person with the baby
for that moment when you are feeling
that experience
there is no time okay so that's our
essential
nature when we are connected with
all that is so when people say i get
i meditate to get away to plug unplug
it's actually inaccurate you get
meditate to pluck
you don't get meditated to
get away from it all you get in touch
with it all
when solitude is not the same thing as
loneliness loneliness comes from the
fear
of the ego itself solitude is being
connected to all that exists
so just make that distinction okay and
you'll see
when you're listening to music do you
think when is this going to end
okay you're listening to a song do you
ask yourself when is the song going to
end
or you're dancing or watching a
ballerina
do you does she think when am i going to
finish
right no because they are in love
and they've become what they're doing so
it is never a problem never a problem
to focus or
concentrate as the word is i don't like
the word concentrate it gives me a
headache just thinking about it
but it is never a problem to focus
on something if you love it
right okay so only do the things that
you love
bringing it back to bliss and do what
you love
where does service fit in can you just
be
always blessed out in your own world and
not
helping others because a lot of what
you're doing is obviously helping other
people with the books and meditation and
fitbit and partnerships and
everything you're doing can you be
totally blissed out
in your own world without serving others
no
in fact if you think of your own world
you will suffer okay so the
wisdom tradition said the following
three things to be happy all the time
following three times now i'm going to
use the traditional words but then i'll
explain it to you
okay so it says first is take
refuge in the buddha buddha is not
a guide it's expanded consciousness
okay take refuge in
a bigger picture rather than
thinking only me and mine take refuge
in the sangha means the community
of fellow beings that
you engage with and last is take refuge
in service or seva the word in
in sanskrit so service
community and shared vision
now i have found is a doctor you know i
still have a license
in massachusetts in california now in
new york and
florida i'm getting a license just to
keep my credentials
but i when i had difficult patience
you know in the past google this that
look at all the books everybody knows
everything
right but how do i treat this one
patient
i used to get everybody who's not in my
specialty i'm an internist
endocrinologist
i used to get generalists
gastroenterologists
oncologists all together in the room
it's a
shared vision we want to cure this
patient
emotional bonding we all care about this
patient together
complementing strengths let's give our
each of us
our opinion on what's the best treatment
soon we had a solution
okay and i realized this is actually the
future
which we call emergence shared vision
emotional and spiritual bonding
complementing each other's strengths
holding each other's back and service
and you're all set
i love it well listen i took a quick
look at the clock and realized we've
been talking we're almost at our time
but it's only felt like five minutes so
thank you for this meditation
uh guys total meditation is the book his
91st book we'll link it up below
fitbit partnership we'll link that up
and in the chopra meditation app as well
deepak again thank you for the time for
for anybody who
just a final message who are trying to
find their bliss who resonate with what
you're saying
what would you leave them with don't
take yourself too seriously
okay just laughter
peace harmony and love remember those
four words peace
harmony laughter love that's it
i love it thank you so much for sharing
for coming on the show thank you very
much
nice to be with you if you want to see
the one on one i did with sad guru check
out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there nobody can cause
mental pain to you
it is you in reaction to something that
happens around you
it is time you take away the nonsense
that's happening within you